il y les mutins il est taquin il est
taquin way i les mutins il est accueilli
les coquins il est qu'aucun heil aime le
sexe c'est un invité mystère à ce que
vous pouvez prendre une autre voie alors
invité mystère alors questions de
matthieu delormeau est ce que vous aimez
le sexe ok voilà à qui nous voilà donc
qui préfèrent les femmes alors on fait
des blagues
il fait des blagues ça lui arrive oui
des questions poser des questions ouais
alors est ce qu il est animateur sur une
chaîne hertzienne 1 2 3 4 5 6 demain
demain oui demain
c est ce que est ce que est ce que on
attend avec impatience la sortie d'un de
ses films oui je sais qui c'est qui
michaël youn
ouais ça va coûter rit oui mais c'est un
temps pensé que tu étais genk c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs pensais que t'étais gay
[Rires]
monica tu sais que tu m'as dis pas parce
qu'on veut pas mettre en danger les
techniciens tu vois pas danger de tt ont
couru tout un tas du temps d août
et sur la planète alors il se passe que
ya un virage qui est arrivé de finale au
corona viège bah oui t'as pas mis au
coin
battant confinement de trouver un amant
moshiri et demain soir et demain soir
moi je suis comme un fou parce que ya
michael ait sur m6 donc là demain on va
terminer l'émission tour à 21h05 on
termine vous passez directement sur
laquelle tu charries l'eau et aux eaux
ils appellent pour insulter connaît
demain c'est une mère pour te faire
pardonner mika est ce que tu peux nous
faire un petit défi la haye avec les
deux cas il faut appuyer sur la télé
parce que l'attaqué pour que la télé
reste allumée vite voilà voilà qu'orange
que dans la commande mais il faut
trouver des corps à droite et quand vite
trouvé l'attaquant rennais pas de monter
mon jeu mais où aller aux [ __ ] à
l'herbe et fabrice sorin arras coca vite
mais non pas ici mais là faut toucher la
télécommande
nonobstant la télé 27 ans
directes 26 secondes mais manier vous le
cul est vrai n'est pas dans notre
culture
regardez vais regarder mais léo ferré ou
comment à faire ajoute à cela c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon c'est ghana j'ai
gagné c'est bon allez on a eu peur mais
michael est ce que tu peux nous faire un
petit défi en facetime est ce que tu as
tu as un balcon tu as une fenêtre
j'adore ta pas une fenêtre
est-ce que tu as mégaphone mais je
croyais qu'on avait toujours un est ce
que tu peux pas sortir à la fenêtre et
ben oui très souvent balayé pas là mais
voilà on pas là on l'aura trimestre dans
un instant michael est ce que tu peux
sortir par la fenêtre
et dire qu'il faut regarder bah il faut
regarder tes pmp tous les soirs en
confinement voilà aucune fait un truc et
vas-y attend ses toiles animateur c'est
bon et c'est bon hanouna j'ai déjà chez
jack là c'est pour toi je te le dire
aujourd'hui j'en ai chié pour toi donc
michaël youn si tu veux si tu peux faire
un petit truc
regardez ils épient les paroles en ce
moment mais maintenant que jacquet les
beaux gosses 1 il est beau gosse en ce
moment il est beau bassin et qu'est ce
tu perds et 10 mois à l'évasion ou la
porte ou laporte fait un truc là fait un
truc me qayoum en direct vas-y direct
c'est dans le direct ça le bruit pour
les hôpitaux
[Musique]
bravo à michael en tout cas les gens te
suivent
tu es dans une rue animée un thé dansant
les gens te suit bain et on t'aime
frérot est dommage ça rappellerait avant
ton émission je t'aime fort salut mon
bébé on l'est même la whey t'inquiète
inquiète et hong lei mieux à la web